hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome with a seven second
challenge with Brian Mathiason Matt say
hi guys hey hello hey we're gonna get
started right away we've got the phone
app pulled up right now Matthias has it
and we're gonna rotate out clockwise and
see who can fail and who can do it so
ready when you are
okay demonstrate three martial arts
moves and name them go
the karate chop of the roundhouse kick
oh [ __ ] my sister graylek am dropkick ah
ah really hurt a shotgun but I did it
right you all did it say like this dude
oh goodness a create your own no it said
it's a demonstration okay yeah you got
me yeah
Oh me Chindi camera is a really cute
baby
all right no no wait baby would you do
that every maybe offer
I don't like be alright so that's how I
treat a big email walk like a robot then
transform into a bicycle go I mean I'm
not impressed
yeah yeah I mean it's like I'm not like
how we're not Wow yeah I'm gonna be a
bicycle no I don't know anyone family
could have been like more uh it is like
I didn't feel you pass you pass it yeah
yeah mayilu but it's but like if you
were doing that out in public I wouldn't
be like that's a bike okay I'd be like
that poor guy say something really
exciting and the most unenthusiastic way
possible I can't wait to go to the water
park and have fun with Jessica because
she's a cool person
hahahahaha what don't you know yes I
know yeah who's Jessica don't don't
who's Jessica why I don't want to know
make it public so ok I want to redo this
whole thing oh come on no she's a friend
a dog no she's she's a friend
name three foods you find delicious that
would be horrible to put on toast go
kimchi sauerkraut and uh pickles
we went over this pickle we did this
come on we said the same holsters what I
need is no pickles on toes that would be
good
well you know I had the items pickle and
bologna sandwiches but never toast yeah
you're right I think it changes up the
dynamic it's just so sweet pickles
that's gross all those things piece
doesn't alright fine fine fine fine
Thank You Man I'm ready
me too name five animals that would be
bad yet Oh gorilla Angelo
chimpanzee goose ha ha ha no no no no
not at all with the majestic I want to
see what that is that's raw an artistic
rendition of what it did out when you're
ready doing this later
well here it is okay okay right revving
agreement baby do rap about yourself go
yo my name is Matt I'm not fat that is
all I have to say about that
who's your Charette feels good I'm not
bad yeah okay guys do you think is the
most fat out of all of us there's
another region there's a bit yeah
there's a lot of Asians that's sounds so
weird though when you say that invent a
cheerleader routine and chant about
someone else who's with you ah good
Matt's not a god dear Oh straight to
that my brain is not you're not even on
camera I don't know you're literally
blocking my damn that camera off that
camera you did nothing right about that
you failed that up all right wait you
depress the button well no I didn't
press the start button cuz obviously
that was terrible
we counted in post my show
Oh a synchronized swimming routine go
synchronize it with yourself pretty good
thanks guys I just felt worse and worse
there's more went on stop ruining my
video for my mention is for outside
there are there we're going to be
looking up where there was an Asian
demonstration for a little Asian
demonstration demonstrating ages yes
pride and well they demonstrate them
describe a jellyfish without using the
word jelly Oh tis a fish in the sea
that's really blubbery and it's clear
and see-through and sticky okay okay
okay we said bloggers ears came to my
pit pretend you are someone from the
1300s adjusting to modern life go oh
this is oh this is all so new accurate
this is also you say it like that say a
sentence that's exactly seven syllables
long go I like peanuts up my butt making
noise you probably wouldn't make it
public you probably know like when you
accidentally pooped yourself
yeah can you do that do it wait was it I
see this oh my god
misting out Oh got it
I did it my hands a bit moist name three
celebrities three and three different
accents go Justin Bieber Melissa
McCarthy James Franco I don't know he
didn't put the official count on you one
you guys do too
I never have a boy and never done that
ever us guys did Emily but then I wasn't
stupid about it like why did you skip it
and I just started counting myself as my
keys all right okay ready scream in five
different ways good yeah well explain to
me what were you screaming at in each
one ah that would be like ah the dog
pooped on the ground and then there's
which is like I love this song and
that's like when I'm older and I find
dog poop and then there's ah that's when
I go through my sex change in fine dog
poop and then oh that's what I have a
heart attack at the end of my life
invent a pickup line using the word
Krusty hey baby physio vagina Krusty it
says jump crab Oh God Jesus Oh God
you made the work of SpongeBob reference
ah God ah I feel bad I want I feel shame
myself like the knowing the knowledge
that when my
my brain is on the line that's where it
goes they said it was wrong when I tried
to have sex with a cow but you would
never say love it laughing now I've
tipped you over on open-field okay so
that was the seven second challenge
thank you everybody so much for joining
us on this horrible adventure where we
discovered that we are not funny not a
one of us nope it's the editing it's all
editing so thanks again everybody for
watching him as always oh sure I forgot
you he's here oh yeah I forgot you thank
you everybody so much for watching thank
you with thanks for joining me man Ryan
thanks for joining us from kids with
problems check him out in the
description of something and as always
we'll see you in the next video bye-bye
you really milk that any [ __ ] you